welcome back to CBS this morning we are
in Washington a city that is captivated
by Christine Blasi for its allegations
against Supreme Court nominee Brett
Kavanaugh we will hear their testimony
in just a few hours a Senate hearing
will take place in Dirksen 226 now
that's a smaller room that normally
would not hold a hearing of this
magnitude let's go back to Norah on
Capitol Hill for what to expect nor I
don't just think that Washington is
captivated by this story I think the
country is really interested in hearing
what dr. Ford has to say today good
morning to you you're right Gail this is
historic almost like the Anita Hill
hearing some 27 years ago I've already
heard from people who have said they've
taken the day off from work because they
want to watch this because it is a
moment in history because not only the
content of what's gonna be discussed but
we're in the midst of a cultural moment
too right now here's what's really
interesting you just showed that room
inside the hearing room but I want to
describe because it's gonna look very
different than some of the hearings
we've covered in the past there will
only be what they call three pool
cameras in there and then they are
limiting the number of still
photographers remember when you see like
for instance someone go testify in a big
hearing there's all these still
photographers that come in well we're
told there are allowing only seven still
photographers in there so it's gonna be
much more intimate in that conversation
they are going to allow just a limited
number of reporters as well inside that
room because in part of Christine Blasi
Ford's in hesitation about a big public
spectacle so they this is in part to
accommodate some of her concerns now
what about the Judiciary Committee what
about the Senators well there this
committee is made up of some of the
oldest longest-serving members of
Congress in fact senator Grassley and
senator Feinstein they're the two
ranking members they're both 85 years
old Walt so some of the youngest
ideological warriors looking right now
at Orrin Hatch and Patrick Leahy they
were actually there on the committee
when Anita Hill testified back in 1991
some other senators to watch for the
Democrats Cory Booker Kamala Harris Amy
Klobuchar all of them have expressed
aspirations perhaps about running for
president in 2020
and Republican Ben Sasse he is someone
to watch as well he has also been seen
as someone who is a future presidential
candidate has bucked his party has
spoken out against Senator Sue's me
President Trump on many occasions now
the committee's top Democrat California
Senator Dianne Feinstein she has been at
the center of this ever since the
beginning remember her office sent a
letter to the FBI about Ford's
accusation just two weeks ago now
yesterday beau Erickson from our Capitol
Hill team snapped this photo of
Feinstein essentially confronting
Republican Lisa Murkowski Lisa Murkowski
is a key swing vote who could up end
Cavanaugh's nomination Murkowski is at
least one of the four undecided
Republican senators along with Susan
Collins Jeff Flake and bob corker and
here's what's key if two of them vote no
Cavanaugh's path to a comer confirmation
is nearly impossible now the Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell he has
said there will be a floor vote on
Kavanagh no matter how he fares in this
committees vote that's interesting we
also know they are going to try and push
this committee vote as quickly as
possible they say they want to vote
tomorrow morning on that but we'll see
we have to listen today to what both dr.
Ford and Kavanagh say all right Nora
can we talk about that photo for just a
second that's one of those things where
you really wish you could be a fly on
the wall it certainly doesn't look like
a friendly conversation it looks very
intense have you heard anything at all
about what the conversation was I'm so
curious what they were talking about we
may never know unless they share it with
us but it's a great picture and most
senators usually keep those
conversations private for a reason but
as you can see they are deep in
conversation and Murkowski has expressed
key concerns about what this hearing is
about that it's not just about Kavanagh
but it is about dr. Ford and the
accusations that she has made and as
many of the Senators specifically the
Democrats have said what's at stake here
- not his qualifications but his
character and I think that's really
going to be why we were gonna see
something very different today because
Gail you mentioned this I think earlier
it's gonna be personal
they're gonna talk about his drinking
habits they're gonna talk about his
sexual habits and so it's gonna be I
think uncomfortable and it might even be
salacious yes yeah nobody wants to talk
about their sexual habits or their sex
life and certainly not in high school
going back to that picture a lot of
people thought well this looks exactly
like what used to be called the Johnson
treatment Lyndon Johnson would get right
in your space as a senator but what's
different from that it's not Lyndon
Johnson and Senator Russell to old
crusty manages to women leaders of the
Senate that's the history that we're in
the middle of now and that's what's so
different about that extraordinary
picture from what we've seen before
thanks Nora